also breaking tonight supreme court
justice samuel alito
has an ominous warning about the
freedoms you hold dear
being under assault during the
coronavirus pandemic
we get details tonight from fox chief
legal correspondent anchor of fox news
at night
shannon breem it pains me to say this
but in certain quarters religious
liberty is fast
becoming a disfavored right supreme
court justice
samuel alito's thursday night speech to
the federalist society hit on hot-button
topics from abortion
to same-sex marriage as he highlighted
wide-ranging covet 19 restrictions
and attacks on religious freedom for
many today
religious liberty is not a cherished
freedom
it's often just an excuse for bigotry
and it can't be tolerated
alito pointed to several prominent cases
as examples
jack phillips the baker in colorado who
declined to make a custom cake for a gay
couple's ceremony
before same-sex marriage was legal in
that state
in washington state a christian
pharmacist who was ordered to provide
the morning after pill which he viewed
as a violation of his deeply held
pro-life
beliefs and the little sisters of the
poor
a group of nuns that has for years been
fighting the obamacare mandate requiring
employers to provide
cost-free access to numerous forms of
birth control
including those the nuns believe equate
to an abortion
as far as i'm aware not one employee of
the little sisters has come
forward and demanded contraceptives
under the little sister's plan
alito also warned about burdensome coven
19 restrictions
keeping many of the faithful from
attending their houses of worship
while casinos and large department
stores remain open
legal experts note in unprecedented
situations like the pandemic
there will always be tension between
individual rights
and the public good the analysis that we
go through every time this happens is
that we don't
want this to be an opportunity for
government overreach and for
infringement on civil liberties
tonight a number of groups on the left
are expressing outrage over alito's
speech calling it overtly political and
inappropriate
especially given that an emergency
appeal from the catholic diocese of
brooklyn
is now pending before the court
challenging governor cuomo's covert 19
restrictions
brett all right shannon thank you see
you tonight at 11